maybe we can get started uh hello
everyone my name is Juan Hu Chen so I'm
currently an assistant professor at
University of Waterloo so I'm also a
faculty member uh at The Bachelor
Institute and c5i chair so uh today I'm
going to talk about deep learning for
NLP right so this is a very broad topic
I'm teaching this whole course at the
University right but now I only have
like an hour to talk about it so I do a
lot of compression and I'm trying to
only highlight some of the key
milestones in the uh in the history of
NLP
and some of the materials will be two
fundamentals so just bear with me yeah
hello commonly everyone's need you know
and so the content we're going to cover
today uh
it's not moving right
okay
yeah so the uh the content we're going
to cover uh consists of like the five
parts so the first one is a recurrent
neural net so basically I'll talk about
what is RNA and what is lstm right and
then I will talk about what is the
tension mechanism right uh basically
like how do you use the tension
mechanism to do all sorts of application
like machine translation image
captioning and so on and so forth
and the and then we're going to talk
about uh Transformers right which is uh
totally built upon uh the attention
mechanism and then once we have the
Transformers right we have like
different types of self-supervised
learning pre-training or so also so on
and so forth like T5 right bird or
whatsoever I'll cover some of this and
then finally I will talk about them
right now I guess the most popular topic
right large language model right and
I'll try to talk about it in context
learning you know prompting and scaling
law this kind of stuff
yeah so if you have any question you can
raise your hand and let me see if I can
make some uh clarification on my end
okay so just a sorry just a very quick
comment if you have questions please use
the mic so that your voice can be
recorded thanks
yeah so uh like let's review some of the
basics right so neural net I I guess
some of you already know like how neural
Nets are working right so neural Nets
consists of like a lot a lot of neurons
right and also uh synapses right
basically the weights be connecting
different uh neurons these are the
learnable parameters we're gonna
optimize this uh parameters to make this
neural natural uh accomplish any tasks
that we desire right so uh in computer
vision there is a convolutional neural
net right which basically takes images
as the input and then try to run some
small convolutional kernels to extract
localized features from the image and
then do some Downstream tasks right like
detections uh image classifications and
so on and so forth right and um
uh and so in NLP right so it's uh we
normally we talk about a lot of tasks
like machine translation uh
summarization image captioning so on and
so forth right a lot of this NLP tasks
can be unified into one format which is
basically a sequence of items as the
input and then a sequence of items as
the output right so the items could be a
lot of things right uh this items in the
sequence could be like Words uh letters
uh image features and so on and so forth
and that's why uh like a predominant uh
like a view of NLP is basically called
sequence to sequence modeling right
so I'm not sure if you can see the video
yeah it says running well and so
sequence to sequence model basically
takes a sequence uh like item by item as
the input and try to Output you know a
lot of items uh like also token by token
right
and then uh the sequence to sequence
model so one of the most popular
architecture is called encoder and
decoder model right so
um it's basically the encoder will
compile the information it receives uh
into a vector right and then after
processing this information and this
Vector will be sent to the decoder and
then the decoder will start generating
those things right like tokens a
paragraphs or anything right
so this is also like kind of a
viralization right so this is a machine
translation task you can think of it as
a sequence to sequence modeling right so
on the left hand side you have like
maybe some French words right you kind
of tokenize them into uh individual
tokens and then you fit these tokens one
by one to an encoder and then the
encoder try to comprehend the meeting
and then compress all the information
right into a vector and then this Vector
will be passed to the decoder model to
start generating maybe like the
translation of the French uh sentence
right something like that
so how does it work right so how does
the encoder uh actually work what's the
underlying mechanism uh so uh the very
basic one is called a recurrent neural
net a recurrent neural net which is
basically a recurrent uh computation
machine right so you can think of it uh
as you know like several component
components here you have the input which
is X where you have also a state and
this is the most important part so the
state will receive the input of X and
then try to update its belief about what
it has perceived so far right and then
it tries to generate uh some output as
all right and so this recurrence can be
unfolded from left to right into you
know this kind of mechanism right so
it's it's basically some sort of
multi-layer perceptron but it's kind of
unrolled in uh to include the time
Dimension as well and a lot of these
weights are shared shared across
different time steps right
so this is a recurrent recursion formula
which is pretty simple right you take
the input and then multiply with the
Matrix and then the previous state also
multiplied with the transition Matrix
right and then you kind of update uh
this day from s t minus 1 to St right
and then you output the out uh like the
the output state of OT by multiplying
another Matrix over as t Okay so this is
the most basic uh recurrent neural
network uh
and then one of the drawback of this
simple design is that it's totally
linear right I'd say it's not able to
capture a lot of this very complex
behaviors in our natural language or any
other sequence to sequence task that's
why people propose like different a more
advanced recurrent neural Nets uh like
one example is this a long short term
memory Network right and there are also
some other variants like a GRU or
something like that
so basically uh in this type of model so
it includes more uh like a non-linearity
basically there are some activation
functions right basically it's composed
of like sigmoid or hypertension you know
that that kind of function so that the
model uh or the architecture can be more
expressive in terms of modeling
different types of behavior and the key
findings of this architecture is that it
has three different
um mechanism one is the forget gate the
other is the input gate and finally they
have like an output gauge which is
basically the Ft for Gap gig I is the
input gate and all right so we can see
there are there's a lot of stuff going
on in this one transition function right
so let's break this down into several
different parts right and for example if
we want to comprehend the sentence right
Bob is a nice person and and then on the
other hand is it's evil right so at the
sentence break right when you start a
new sentence we do want to forget about
like bubble whatsoever right and then
start a new sentence right so that's why
uh the lstm introduced this mechanism of
forget engage right so at some uh step
right so the model tries to uh predict
like a number between 0 and 1 which
means that how much memory should I keep
from the last stage if this is like a
new sentence probably I just throw away
all the memories about like the previous
context and start from you know
beginning if I'm in the middle of the
sentence right I should probably have
like a higher uh value of like
rechaining the past context so the
forgetting uh will be kind of disabled
right so this is one gate
the other gauge is the input gate right
so uh the input gate controls how much
information flows uh from the input of X
right so for example in for example in
the same sentence right if you talk
about Bob here and about there right so
there are some new contacts uh
describing Bob right you want to have
this uh new information being kind of
merged or fused into the uh into the
original like context vector and this is
called like in the input gate right
and once you have like the input and uh
and the forget gate and then you have
the context right so from this context
uh this context is uh presumably
multi-physical because it captures like
a lot of aspects right about Bob right
and but like right here if we want to
generate the next word right so it's
reflecting a certain aspect of Bob right
so that's why we need some uh to choose
or select some aspect of out of uh the
hidden states that we have and that's
why we have the output gate so the
aggregate will be like more like a
selective module uh trying to uh like uh
only select the most relevant
information out of the context right so
these are like the three uh big modules
inside the lstm to capture different
sorts of behaviors right like in because
in your in your sentence on your
paragraph sometimes you need to forget
right and you need to star from scratch
and sometimes you need to digest the
information and sometimes you need to
select which information to uh output
right so this is the underlying
mechanism of lstm right
so uh so for lstm it can be also used
for machine translation right so the
basic idea is that uh for a lot of these
words right we can use word embedding uh
and the YouTube word can be represented
as a vector right so these vectors will
be basically the X from here right
and you have this X and then you run
through the lstm mechanism that I talked
about right try to process uh this x one
by one and try to get you know the
context Vector of this lstm right and
then you have this context fracture and
then you have another lstm which is the
decoder that tries to uh condition on
the context and trying to Output uh the
words token by token it's basically uh
there are a lot of optimizable
parameters in this both of this lstm so
you can optimize it to generate the
things that you want right try to kind
of twist it to do the things that you
want basically
so here you know like this is an example
of a neural machine translation using
our CM right so you fit this word by
word right and then you use the last
hidden stage of the lstm and then you
fit it into the decoder and then the
decoder will also go through this lstm
and try to generate a token by token
and now uh so and then we're gonna move
on to uh the attention mechanism right
so one of the problem of the previous uh
like uh approach is that we only and
there are two uh problems one is that
we're basically processing uh the input
like token by token right uh for example
uh if there are two tokens at the ice
position and Chase position uh you
literally need to run the model like J
minus I steps right to let these two
tokens interact with you with each other
right so this is very common in natural
language we have a lot of co-reference
right this course structure we keep
referring to things that we talked about
right but sometimes these words can be
separated you know uh far apart right
and uh so these kind of like token by
token architecture uh cannot capture
this kind of long dependency very well
and secondly uh as you can see in the
last uh video right so the model
basically compress all the information
from the encoder side into one vector
sometimes this Vector you know this
Vector is a fixed size Vector right for
example you feel like have like a whole
paragraph right it's impossible to
compress all of them into just one
vector
yeah so how can we make this model more
flexible right is it is there an easy
fix uh so in this uh in this part I'll
mainly talk about how we address uh the
second issue right how to make the
context Vector uh more flexible
right so uh which is easy right
basically uh previously we only passed
one vector from the encoder to the
decoder right so maybe we can just fit
all the vectors from the encoder to
decoder right this is a very easy fix
right so it goes through the encoder ion
you get one first one uh first hidden
State and then the second and then the
third you just compile them together and
then feed all of them to the decoder
right and then the decoder will be able
to you know like be able to figure out
what to grab from the encoder side
instead of like the encoder to decide
what should I compress right so that's
what we call that attention mechanism uh
like in from the decoder side so uh the
attention decoder doesn't actually stop
before producing this output it
basically looks at the set of encoder
hidden States so each encoder hidden
state is mostly associated with so
certain are worse because it's produced
like token by token right and we're
gonna so the decoder will give
each of the Hidden State uh a score
basically like how relevant uh this
stage is with respect to the one things
that I want to Output right and then
we're going to multiply each hidden
state by its soft Max score and thus
amplifying on the hidden state that are
relevant to my output and then throwing
away the hidden states that are
irrelevant to what I'm I want to pursue
right so in order to better understand
this you can see this video right so
basically you have let's say here you
have some encoder hidden State like H1
h2h3 you know for example this is very
simple visualization let's say we only
have three words right and then we want
to decode the hidden State for the time
step four right and then now we kind of
attend to all this uh encoder hidden
stage and then we gotta we get their
score right so basically how relevant
they are and but this is not normalized
right we can use some soft Max you know
uh like normalization to get a
distribution of all this and then you're
gonna multiply uh the soft Max score
with all this hidden State and then
aggregate them into one vector right so
this Vector will represent what I need
from the output from the encoder output
right so this is pretty Dynamic uh and
it's just doing very well in a lot of
cases so the attention flow like more
formally can be expressed as this so the
IM processes output and processes input
producing an output and a new hidden
State Vector H4 so because now it's at
the fourth stack right
so in the attention step we're going to
use the encoder hidden States and the X4
Vector to calculate the context Vector
for this step right you basically using
the mechanism of weighted sum that I
just mentioned and then we can't catch
an H4 and C4 into one vector and this
Factor will be fed into another feed
forward neural network and this neural
network will decide which word to Output
right we're gonna so this is basically
the the fourth step uh computation right
we can repeat this for any number of
times right
so here is another video of teaching you
how to do this right so here you we are
at the fourth step right because now we
because we already have like uh three
like encoder hidden stage right and
we're generating the fourth one so we
will uh fit like the start token here
and then we will have like the H4 uh
it's like some initialized uh vector and
then I will use this to query uh all
these hidden steps right so there are
one two three four of them right and
then you calculate the soft Max score
and then you do the uh weighted sum
right and then you get uh this hidden
stage which is C4
and then you concatenate C4 and H4
together and then put that into a fit
forward neural network and then it will
generate the work right
hopefully this is I right and then on
this I uh will be like this embedding
will fit into the step five and then you
just go through like the whole thing
again but and then
it will attend to you know all this uh
in Hidden State uh encodation States
again right now it's attending to a
different thing right because when you
are translating you your position moves
right you attend two different contacts
right depending on the position of your
decoder
and then you feed it to maybe like a uh
to get a C5 feed forward neural network
and then you generate the output of M
right so on and so forth you can run
this uh until uh like some like end of
sentence token or whatsoever
and one thing that we uh observe is that
uh if you plot out the attention map
like a tension map basically is you know
like the soft Max score right so let's
say this is this is like the decoder
side and this is the encoder side right
so when I'm translating the first word
it lays a lot of uh uh attention on this
word like this French word what I'm
translating this the attention uh kind
of highlights on this right so on and so
forth you can see there's like uh the
overarching like diagonal Trend right so
if you look if you know French and
English you can see that uh this uh
token uh from English and French they're
aligned very well right so which also
enhances on the uh interpretability of
the model right
and even more we could you know uh
generalize this attention-based lstm
um to do image captioning as well right
so what we're going to do is that
instead of like using RNs to process uh
word test input we can use cnns to
process image as the input right now we
have like uh the CNN gonna give us you
know like a feature map right so you can
flatten this feature map just like the
uh the ions right so you will have a lot
of localized features extracted from the
input image and then you use the rstm
with some attention mechanism and then
try to generate you know the caption
word by word and as you can see uh some
of the people I think this was uh uh
published in at Miller in 2015 and this
is a very highly cited paper so if you
can visualize the attention right so you
can see like when it's gen when the
captioning model is generating but it
tries to you know attend to bird most of
the time when it's generating like
something like water or something right
it blacks out you know blocks out the
the uh the bird well attend more to the
surrounding water right or something
like that so this is very fancy at that
time people have never seen such kind of
mechanism so that's why it arouses a lot
of interest in the uh in pursuing this
uh type of uh you know interpretable
generative model
and then that's why we have the
Transformer model right so I already
talked about like how to kind of break
the uh let me see what's the time so
it's one it's already one oh okay yeah
so to 230 right okay sounds good so the
uh like we already talked about how we
break the bottleneck of the like the
context Vector right so we haven't
touched on upon the other weakness which
is how can we uh
let's capture the long-term dependency
between tokens that are further apart
right in the input right and how can we
make it more flexible if you look at the
recurrent neural network architecture if
you unroll it from left to right you
know you can see that uh you know
something like this right and the
encoder uh so the ins and tries to use
the inductive buyers that uh like all
the sequences uh a lot of the contacts
are local right they try to process
things locally which is a good heuristic
but it also has some bottleneck right
for example the RNs gonna take the order
of sequence length time and to make the
distance word interact with each other
right so for example if you are
processing this sentence right the chef
uh who blah blah blah blah and words
right and then this words and Chef they
are you know their High highly connected
right so but there might be you know
already I mean 100 tokens in between
right so the model already forget what's
going on with the chef you know maybe
Miss remembers that it's not a chef it's
a maybe a doctor or maybe a policeman or
something like that right so this could
cause a lot of issues and when we're
doing NLP right so
um it's so with this uh like kind of uh
linearized recurrence uh it's very hard
for us to learn the long distance
dependency and this is mainly because
the gradient propagation issue because
as uh it's using uh the uh VP TT
algorithm
and you you basically need to propagate
the gradient for many steps uh from here
to here to actually learn the long-term
dependency so this learning Paradigm uh
basically prevents the model from like
getting capturing this long-term
dependency and so uh this is not the
what the best way to do an LP right so
someone and so that's why like uh in I
think in 2017 or something right so
Google has published this paper called
attention is all you need and basically
uh proposed that proposed that we don't
even need the recurrent architecture we
can just use attention for the whole
network the whole network is just built
upon attention mechanism how can we do
that right so are we gonna use uh uh
like the attention gonna treat each
words representation as a query right
and then I'm trying to access and
incorporate information
um from the entire sequence right so
there is no recurrence at all here and
the one good thing about this is uh it
can be done uh in a very highly
parallelized way you know like because
in GPU right it has a lot of this uh
parallelized computation unit uh if you
use Transformer it can best exploit you
know the parallelism uh residing inside
the uh the the GPU
so right now because there is no kind of
recurrence the maximum interaction
distance or the complexity for two
tokens to interact with each other
suddenly drop to constant right or one
basically and all the words will
interact with each other at all level
right so for example here in the second
layer you know so this word uh this
hidden state is going to interact with
all the input word embedding right and
then you're gonna choose to do this
self-attention over this whole layer and
then you're gonna stack another self
attention layer on top of that and then
you on this layer you can also kind of
uh interact with all the hidden States
from the last last layer so on and so
forth you can stack this you know maybe
100 layers of you know to capture all
sorts of very sophisticated interactions
between different uh words and so on and
so forth so attention can be seen as
performing a very fuzzy lookup in a key
value store so in a lookup table we have
a table of key and values right
basically if here we are having a word
as a query uh and then we try to grab
the most relevant words out of this
inventory of the key and value Pairs and
then we're going to do the output right
but if you're going to design it this
way like some hard Steel action this is
not differentiable so that's why they do
like a more soft version of uh like
local right so this is also based on the
attention mechanism that I already
talked about you just compute like the
uh like the score which reps back to
each of that key value pair and then and
do a soft Max over all of them and then
do the weighted song to calculate all of
them right so but in this case most of
the time the softmax try to polarize you
know the and the attention weights and
then if you look at the the attention
it's mostly specified and then the model
is only kind of attending to you know
several individual key value pairs
so this is like the transformer encoder
which consists of two part one is the
self-attention layer that I talked about
where like the model kind of attend to
resolve and then it's all this nearby
tokens in within the sequence and then
after that we will have like another
feed forward neural network uh trying to
add more expressivity Express uh uh like
power into it like adding more
non-linearity or so on and so forth
right so here if we have only have two
words right we can help design like the
self attention layer and then it will
let these two tokens interact with each
other to get the representation of Z1 Z2
and then you're gonna put that through
like a feed forward neural network to do
the uh to calculate the the real output
of this single block right and then you
can do this like layer by layer right so
for example if you have n in code layers
you're going to repeat this process
until you finally reach the uh the the
like the the last layer
so here is basically representing like
repeating what I've said right basically
if you have two words right you're gonna
uh project their word embedding uh into
three uh 3D key vectors to three
different vectors one is the query
Vector one is the Q vector and one is
the uh value Vector right and then
you're gonna use the query and key to
calculate one score right so this is
basically dot product and uh and then
you can see you have like this two dot
product and then you normalize it into
the soft Max right and then you combine
uh you can like combine them with the
weighted sum and then you will get Z1 so
basically the thing I will find it after
the self attention will also generate
like one vector and similarly for
machine you will do the same thing and
then it will generate another vector and
uh like in a nutshell this can be
expressed in a matrix format like this
um
and like another uh very smart design in
this is in this Transformer is that it
not only has one attention it has
multiple attention parallel attention
which we call is multi-hat Right
multi-head attention increases the
model's capacity to attempt differently
right so basically like in this world it
probably like in this aspect you turn to
this word right maybe it's trying to
express something you attend to some
other words so there are different like
uh uh this could increase the model's
capacity to leverage different attention
uh from the input right
and what it what it does is basically
you have like this multi uh tension you
know output right you just concatenate
all of them together and then you go
through another projection layer to
finally combine them all this all this
multi-head into one output
and yeah so there are some later
normalization after this right I'll just
fast forward this part and then you can
uh stack a lot of this self-attention
layers on top of each other and on the
decoder part it's also self-attention
and but there is another caveat it's not
only attending to itself but it's also
attending uh to the encoder output right
so here you're going to switch out how
you calculate the key and value uh and
pairs you know it's not coming from
itself it's basically coming from the
ones that you already calculated by the
encoder
and then we're going to talk about
self-supervised learning right so
Transformer is basically the most
important architecture right now so a
lot of the work has been done on top of
Transformers all right and uh so here we
just assume that we have like a
Transformer model so uh like one of the
key uh uh like uh tasks in natural
language processing is called language
model right language modeling is
basically trying to predict the next
word given the past context right and uh
so uh like and actually in order to
learn this uh you don't actually need
any annotation or any supervised data
because it's basically just you grab
some context from the web right and then
you can have some past contacts and to
predict the next tokens on and so forth
this is what we call a self supervision
right so it's not supervised by any
human or anything or more explicitly
right so and is trying to get the signal
from the web right and
try to infuse this into the neural
neural parameters and then uh once we
train this model to perform this
language modeling we can save this
pre-trained model as the checkpoint and
then once we do some like Downstream
tasks we're going to initialize our
weights from the saved checkpoint so
that we could do do the optimization
more efficiently right so for the
self-supervised learning there were a
lot of stuff going on at that time I
think I remember it in like 2018 2019 or
2020 there are different uh studies
trying to investigate what is the best
self-supervised objective right so uh
like the open AI trust is the next token
prediction they have been always doing
this uh even in gpd3 so the basic idea
is very simple you just have the path
you have a sentence you you found from
like the web right and then you mask the
next word like not some word and and
then use the pass window the previous
window and then try to predict that
right that's called Next token
prediction and then also some other work
like birds who tries to explore another
alternative where you have like a whole
sentence and then you mask one of the
tokens right and then you try to predict
this word not only from the left hand
side but also from the right hand side
right
and
and there are also other objectives for
example if you have a complete sentence
and then you have another you know some
other sentence you're going to predict
which one is the sentence that follows
this sentence or there are some other
also other sentence reordering tasks
where you kind of uh perturb uh this uh
all the words inside the sentence and
then you try to reconstruct their
original ordering right so there are
tons of papers in investigate in this
like gbdtube Roberta Ernie T5 Albert
Bard
ul2 so on and so forth there are plenty
of them
and uh so some of them are using like
decoder only architecture where
basically like the whole architecture
just a decoder there's no encoder at all
some examples are like gb2 gbt3 Lambda
and there are some only using the
encoder and there's no decoder like bird
and some other variants like Roberta
whatsoever
and there's also like encoder decoder uh
architecture like Transformers T5 bar to
so on and so forth right
and so now like with all this uh super
self-supervised learning so the
community shifted to another Paradigm
where well whatever we do we first try
to pre-train the model on some
self-supervised tasks and then we
fine-tune on our uh end task like
machine translation you know dialogue
anything right so this has bumped the
score uh up by a lot right so if you
look at like the fine tune Transformer
model so like for example like the gpt2
right it's able to achieve uh soul type
performance on a lot of the uh the the
benchmarks uh like uh here these are
like some I think it's natural language
inference task and then also some
reading comprehension tasks right so
people have observed that with this
pre-training uh the end model
performance can jump a lot uh in a lot
of the cases
and then finally we're going to talk
about a large language model right so
large language model has been very
popular you know so this is before uh
gpt3 right as you can see Elmo uh is
also like a pre-training master which
was proposed in 2017 which only uses 94
million parameters and then we have like
GPT uh Bird right Transformer Almo gpt2
so on and so forth most of them are only
uh residing in the regime of like half
several hundreds of millions of
parameters except the Nvidia one which
is the the Megatron RM which has a eight
mil a billion parameters
and then uh lgbt3 come out right you can
see that all these models come they
compare so small uh like with respect to
gbd3 gbd3 just increases from like a
hundreds of millions to hundreds of
billion you know it's a thousand times
larger than all the other models
so it's crazy like one uh of the key
observation uh from Auckland AI is that
it's called scaling law scaling law
means that if you train this on this
pre-trained this large language model
and then you observe at its final like
converged test loss test loss is
basically a perplexity it's basically
telling you how perplexed you are in
terms of generating the next token on uh
on our validation coppers or something
like that so presumably the lower tax
loss means that the model is better it
correlates very well with the downstream
task and as you can see uh like uh so
this is basically a linear line it means
that we the openly I found that uh the
more compute you throw in uh the better
model you can get and then it also
scales uh log linearly right if you use
the the empirical results and then you
uh you try to fit it it's almost one
line it's almost a line right so with
this you can almost uh deterministically
predict how well your model is by a
specific compute and it's also locked
linearly with respect to the Token the
data set size that you are training at
like basically how many tokens you have
uh in your data set right so here there
are scales from like a few million to I
think this is like a billion right so
right now the models that we're training
are using like hundreds of uh billions
of tokens and then it's also linearly
log linearly scales with the uh the
parameter size of the model
uh and and you can see that gpd3 uh
tries to uh investigate it what would be
the outcome if we train a lot of these
models right they from like small medium
large Excel so on and so forth until
175 billion which is stupidly three
right so we can see that uh all these
models they fit this uh like their
lowest point right in the converging
test on validation loss it fits this
line very well this is a huge Discovery
it basically give us a guide of how well
I can actually get which when I throw in
this amount of compute or something like
that right
and then uh with these models
um now like an openly I found like a new
way to use this model basically you
don't need to uh kind of fine tune it at
all you just prompt it and then it will
generate things that you want right so
there are different prompting
methodology there's no prompt one which
means that there's no natural language
instruction you just give it some
examples right like there are zero short
a one shot a few shots right and then
there's ones with a natural language
instruction basically telling the model
what you are doing and also giving you
uh some sort of like a demonstration
about how this task is being solved
and then the income tax learning you
know basically when you are doing
gradient descent over the model it
implicitly learns how to do the income
tax learning
and so what this model like and so here
are some of the examples right so you're
basically having some sort of imitation
demonstration then the model kind of
imitate uh the behavior very well and uh
so the income tax learning is defined as
you know uh for as following so the
model develops a pattern recognition
abilities while training uh which can be
applied to inference time so the
capability is emergent as the model
scale up scales up which means that when
the model is small uh the model like the
model can't do this uh in contextual
anywhere well but if you scale it up to
like 100 billion parameters it suddenly
learns how to do it and and then do it
very well right basically
and uh so however if you look into the
unsupervised learning objective there's
no explicit guidance to teach to teach
the model how to do income tax learning
how to imitate you know a few
demonstration and then and do do the
like same thing on unseen input but
there are a lot of active ongoing
research trying to investigate why how
this kind of behavior emerge
uh and uh so these are some of the uh
like results uh provided by open AI so
during the training uses some various
exactly tasks like uh remove a random
symbol from a word right and and you as
you can see uh by increasing the
demonstration examples the model tries
to uh like get as much and much better
performance and as you can see the uh
the larger the model gets the
performance uh it will increase
dramatically you know from like 20 to 60
percent something like that and one
thing that we also observe is that when
you have enough examples you don't even
need the natural language instruction
there's even there's no problem and you
just give it some uh like examples the
model can already reach the same
performance with the counterpart with
natural language instruction
awesome
uh could you repeat the question I'm
sorry oh yeah I'm sorry so uh you were
saying that uh how does the model
evaluate this right
foreign
so they basically use a synthetic task
so basically requires the model to
remove a random symbol from an input
sequence like a ABCD right tries to
remove any maybe C or D or anything
right and then generate like the output
so this is a very easy task just trying
to do some uh diagnostic about like
whether model can learn this very simple
skill
the the parameters learnable parameters
from the model
yeah so there are like uh 1.6 1.3
billion parameter 13 billion parameter
and 100 175 billion parameters as you
can see you know as you scale up the
model the performance is going to jump
uh very significantly
and so that's like some synthetic tasks
right let's look at some more more
realistic house task called trivial QA
so this comprises of a lot of questions
from this trivia uh QA test and it's
asking about like some random knowledge
in our daily life right so you can see
that as the model scales up you know the
performance can improve very
significantly you know like from uh
maybe like 10 to 30 to 50 until like 70
or something and what surprises us is
that the model hasn't converged yet
right it's kind of uh like improving
linearly right now so which means that
if you scale the model to like a
trillion parameter or something maybe
you can already get a hundred percent
accuracy so this is uh very intriguing
uh basically you you give it uh the
model like some sort of examples to
imitate right basically
yeah that's why like the the Improvement
is not very dramatic right just a few
percentage of uh if you look at that
right so it's only like a few percentage
Yeah
uh but but you at least need like one
example to actually teach the model what
is the format right of the answer
something like that but giving it you
know like 64 63 more you know you only
get a very small jump like maybe seven
or five percent you know something like
that
and then the gpd3 if you're gonna
evaluate it on some of the uh you know
the major NLP tasks like machine
translation and uh whatsoever like
machine uh like reading comprehension
right without training the model at all
you just give it like a few short
example and then do prompting the model
is already getting a very good
performance on a lot of this tasks and
these results are coming from 2020 so
these are pretty old right now uh I
assume I assume that with gbt4 you
already get like much much higher
performance
so uh what why is uh in context learning
so good right why is the same so people
love in context learning so much I guess
uh one reason being that the previous
method still requires them all due to
fine-tune the model right the fine
tuning is kind of it's very expensive uh
the expense comes from two sides one is
that if you want to do gradient descent
you need a lot of uh gpus right GPU
memory or whatsoever and then you also
need to find out to fine-tuning the
model you need to save the checkpoint in
your disk right like each of the
checkpoint could be you know like tens
of gigabytes right which is very
expensive to save right but now with
income tax learning you don't need to do
any uh gradient descent at all you just
uh uh give it some prompt and then it
does everything for you and then one
single model can solve all the tasks
without any adaptation you know the
adaptation is only on the input right so
what kind of input you try to give it
you know what kind of demonstration you
give it that's why prompt engineering
becomes you know like very popular
fashion right now
and yeah so we start I want to conclude
this talk